Okay. Now...
-I--
-WOMAN: I love you, Bill!
I love you too.
I... usually say,
"I know why you're happy,"
I don't know why you're happy,
I know why I'm happy.
Because Kim Jong Un
of North Korea
yesterday, told South Korea
that he is willing to meet with
the leader of the United States.
But Putin wasn't available,
so Trump's going.
-(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-Trump is going...
Fat man and little boy...
-(LAUGHTER)
-...are gonna have a date.
It looks like Trump is gonna
travel to North Korea in May,
and, of course, there are
reasons, a hundred reasons,
why this is dangerous.
We're talking about, after all,
a family that has reneged
on every deal they ever signed.
And Kim Jong Un
can't be trusted either.
(LAUGHTER)
Uh...
But, you know what...
(APPLAUSE)
I was watching all
the cable news last night,
and to all these liberals
who are reflexively
hating on this:
A, Obama, remember him?
Proposed the exact same thing
in 2008, and they loved it,
and, B, you know, fuck you.
You don't live
on the west coast,
where a nuke can get here faster
than an Uber from North Korea.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
I mean, what is this bullshit?
"No president
has ever done this."
Yeah, and they all failed!
So I'm gonna file
this one under,
"So crazy it just might work."
This could be the one thing
that Trump, honestly,
is uniquely qualified
to pull off,
because Kim and him,
Rocket Man and Rain Man...
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
...are mirror images.
In a weird way, they respect
and like each other.
You know, Trump said
he's a smart cookie,
they have the same interests,
flattery, celebrity, tyranny...
(LAUGHTER)
They both have daddy issues
and overeating issues,
and problematic family members,
and inexplicable hair.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
(CHEERING)
They both love missile parades,
and they both lie
on their golf scores, and...
One day you see staff members
working for them,
and the next day,
they disappear.
(LAUGHTER)
Who...
Who is the one American
that Kim likes?
Dennis Rodman.
Well, Trump is the closest thing
we're gonna get
to President Dennis Rodman.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
Another stupid argument
I heard on TV last night,
"Well, we'll just be giving Kim
the respect he and his family
have always craved."
So what?
So what if it works?
My old pot dealer
used to hang out with me
because I'm a celebrity,
I still got free weed.
And you know what this--
If you hate Trump
so much-- I do,
this might not even be happening
because of Donald Trump.
It could be his tough talk.
It could be
because of the sanctions,
could have been
because of the Olympics.
Who knows what is
in Kim Jong Un's mind?
It could be because
Shape of Water won Best Picture,
and he saw that, and thought,
"Well, if you can fuck a fish,
you can negotiate with a whale."
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-(WHISTLING)
-BILL: But...
Hey, North Korea is
not the only place
Trump will be traveling to.
Next week, he's coming here.
To California. Isn't that great?
He-- he didn't want to,
but this is where
the porn stars are.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
Uh...
Oh, you've been following that?
We now have a full-on
sex scandal in the White House.
Stormy Daniels is now
suing him.
That was the development
this week.
On Monday, she filed
a lawsuit.
Now, if you forgot who she is,
Stormy Daniels, if you recall...
(LAUGHS)
Okay, the man who got
eighty percent of
the evangelical vote
for president 2016,
and the star of
Toxic Cumload 6...
(AUDIENCE GROANS)
(LAUGHTER)
...met at the--
at a golf tournament in 2006,
after which she was paid
to shut up about it,
but Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
this week, really fucked up,
and she said in
the press briefing
that Trump won
an arbitration case...
with her. A lie,
that contradicted
her original lie
that Trump had nothing
to do with Stormy Daniels,
so now it's just
a he said, she said.
Stormy says they had an affair,
and Trump says they didn't.
But who are you gonna believe?
The fake blonde with big tits,
or Stormy Daniels?
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
I couldn't wait to do that one,
I must tell you.
(LAUGHTER)
But here's the thing,
Stormy Daniels' not
suing for money.
She is suing for
the right to talk
about the fat disgusting
Trump sex that she had.
She wants to get out of
the non-disclosure agreement
she signed
and Trump's lawyers this week
said they want to issue
a gag order,
and she said,
"That costs extra."
-(LAUGHTER)
-So...
Uh-- But... (LAUGHS)
But here's why... (LAUGHS)
Here's why she has a case.
Because in
the settlement papers...
First of all,
in the settlement papers,
Trump goes by an alias.
An alias, David Dennison.
David Dennison,
because Dirk Diggler
was too on-the-nose.
But those--
The settlement might be invalid,
because Trump--
-I mean Dirk Diggler...
-(LAUGHTER)
...forgot to sign it!
This happens a lot
to a stable genius.
-(LAUGHTER)
-Uh...
But, you know, Trump,
he's always going on about
"Other countries
are laughing at us,"
Oh-- Uh-- Wh--
And now? Really?
And not even because
the president fucks porn stars,
but because she has
a better lawyer.
(APPLAUSE)
(LAUGHS) Trump... Trump...
Donald Trump managed to find
the one woman in America
to have sex with him
who then wanted
to talk about it.
(LAUGHTER)
Usually, when he has sex
with someone, he says,
"Don't tell anyone," and
they're like, "Not a problem."
(LAUGHTER)
(LAUGHS)
But the best part is that
the documents say that
this Stormy Daniels has, quote,
"certain still images,"
I-- which, to me, sounds like
dick pics, right?
What-- what else can
"still images" that
he doesn't want out there--
And you can tell it's
Trump's dick in the picture,
because, well, two reasons.
First, there's a big sign
on top of it, "Trump penis".
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
And also, it's in
Sean Hannity's mouth.
Anyway...